you're going to see a lot of pink
throughout the ballpark and rightfully
so
to honor cancer survivors tonight's
starting pitcher
for the tigers is right-hander matt
manning his sixth major league career
sixth start of the year
pitchers pitching teammates today and
they were talking about his
athleticism and he gets a quick out
there
could be two perfect short to harold
castro
nicely done and that's how the inning
ends
and it'll be jordan lyles going tonight
for the rangers this will be his
19th game you see the five and six
record 5.20 era
it's a weak tapper left side of the
infield holt charges and throws out
badou
one away hits this one
sharply on the ground to third holt to
his left and he throws out scope
robbie grossman we talked about him
early in the pregame too what a great
job he's done
here's the 2-2 to grossman you got it
sends one to deep right field
that goes gallo he'll turn and watch it
fly
a second straight night where robbie
grossman hits a first inning homer
and he's given the tigers a one-nothing
lead
what a power season for robbie grossman
well it's amazing this guy we're telling
you all the
good the bad and the ugly right what
does he do he sits on a hang and
breaking ball it's
center cut great extension great focus
balls out you know it just like last
night this one was pulled a little more
down the line
but without a question that one was
going out and now matt manning goes to
work in the second
the shift on gallow this one hit up the
middle that's a base hit
is this ball hard deep out to center
field that one
will bang off the wall gallow into third
base
and tony beasley waves him to the plate
he will score without a throw
a deep run-scoring double by john hicks
and the rangers have tied it in the
second inning zach short
stands in with harold castro on first
and one away
short turns on one sends it to deep left
field that's got a chance and that ball
is
gone a two-run blast for
zach short his fourth of the season and
the tigers punch
right back this time he's able to get
the barrel out and pull the ball
had a little bit better launch angle and
it's enough to hit a home run it's a
hanging slider
that dreaded hanging slider for pitchers
and zach short keeps it fair just inside
the foul pole
down the left field line with a two run
lead matt manning battles the number
nine one and two hitters
for texas the 1-1
grounded to short
no problem for zach short run away
oh right back at manning and he gloved
it and stole the base hit away from
brockhole
matt manning's got the fortitude to
stick his glove right there
i mean that takes focus it's a breaking
ball that's hit
really hard i'm not sure but i bet it's
over 100 miles an hour
slowly to second base harold castro
retires nathaniel lowe
bottom third rangers trailing the tigers
three to one
kill badou strikes out to start the
third
[Music]
scope strikes out swinging two away
he's at a career-high 15 home runs right
now switch hitter lines that one out to
center and the inning is done runner in
scoring position for hicks now
i need the out there it is that second
look back kind of stopping
ace struck him out foul tipped it into
the glove
of grace and grinder his first punch out
of the night
makes out number two in the four
it'll be up to david dahl now
david turns this one over first and down
that right field line into the corner
that'll get garcia home easily
dull into second base and he'll be
content
with a two-out rbi double not sure this
ball is located middle in
and this is a bat the rangers would love
to see get going a little bit easy rbi
as you can see garcia pulling up a
little bit
here's the 2-2 he sits him down away
limits the damage rangers played one in
the fourth
he'll go to work here in the fifth and
try to keep the game right where it is
3-2 tigers
wave and a miss that's quick work by
matt manning
strikes out culverson on three pitches
two fastballs and then he went with the
good slider there
takes you a little while then you find
your rhythm things start going so lack
to deep right center field grossman got
a good jump and tracks it down for out
number two
the one two grounded to jonathan scope
at first he'll lead
manning and the rangers go one two three
for the second time tonight
well this game's a long way from end and
they only have the one run lead
so right got to keep grinding it out 3-1
to aquil badu
fly ball right center field
back goes eli white and he leaps and
it's gone
akil badu showing some big time
power and big time flare
this ball just kept carrying and
carrying and cleared the
seats out there or the fence i should
say and right center field
right on top of that yellow line
but that's an important run and the
tigers have a man in scoring
position now for harold castro now
castro and again he goes the other way
with it a base hit into left field
here comes candelario the throat of the
play
got him a
hopper from david dahl and they gunned
down candelario to
in the inning tremendous play here by
david dahl the aggressiveness and the
accuracy
and don't forget about john hicks on the
other end he couldn't see that ball for
a little while did that go between
candelario's legs
that was amazing matt manning lasted a
career-high
six innings he gives way here
in the seventh to joe jimenez
the 2-2 to david dahl
a strikeout to start the seventh and the
night for joe jimenez
to pop up behind the dish grayson griner
loses the mask and there's two away
on a line and akiel badu is right there
good inning joe jimenez retires the
rangers on 10 pitches
and brett martin replaces lyles after
seven
pretty strong innings first pitch
swinging
and badou rolls it down there to first
base low beats him to the base
one pitch one out in the eighth jonathan
scope
needs a hit to extend his season best
hitting streak to 11.
up the middle on the backhand
he got it he's got the infield single
jonathan scopes hitting streak
is extended to 11 in a row
shot toward the right field corner on
the run is joey gallo he dives and he
makes the catch
joey gallow with a diving grab just
inside the line he left his feet on the
grass he landed along the track
and he takes care of cabrera for the
final out here in the eighth gregory
soto
is on to work tonight nine out of ten in
save situations
good slider pops it up left side of the
infield
here's jamer candelario putting it away
[Applause]
fly ball deep left center field hill
giving chase
he's got it shy of the wall
pops this one up back of first base that
could be at a tough spot
and it drops in fair 2-2 pitch
oh that got him and so white is on the
tying runs are on base
or on a night where he makes a mistake
and it could be the
soto prime to do that this will be his
20th pitch of the inning
is
wow so the tying run will be in scoring
position now
another one too high chopper to short
short takes care of it and the tigers
take care of the rangers again
the winning streak is at six